unsere regierung spielt schwarzer peter
ihre komplette im planung fährt gerade
kräftig vor die wand und jetzt will es
niemand gewesen sein
der gesundheitsminister verteidigt sich
die kanzlerin hat angeblich alles
richtig gemacht die eu schiebt den
schwarzen peter den pharmakonzern zu und
ganz am ende bleibt als einzige
schuldige angeblich das virus selbst in
der seit jahrzehnten größten krise
unseres landes wird sich jetzt einfach
weggeduckt verdrückt wer verantwortet
jetzt das größte politische versagen in
dieser corona krise wer ist schuld an
diesem impfstoff desaster
die regierung selbst finde ich muss
diese antwort geben denn wir brauchen
jetzt denjenigen der zuständig ist das
alles aufzuräumen dass endlich schneller
geimpft wird jemanden der aufsteht und
mutig voran geht und sagt ich mach's ich
bin deutschlandsim manager ich bestelle
jetzt den impfstoff ich verpflichte die
pharmaindustrie den stoff herzustellen
und zwar rund um die uhr
ich sorge bis in jedes dorf dafür dass
der so schnell wie möglich zu den
menschen kommt und wenn irgendwas
schiefgeht dann steht nicht dafür gerade
deutschland sucht diesen im manager
deutschland braucht ein in velden